la comisión europea Úrsula thunderleyen
asegura que Rusia ha llevado el
conflicto a un nivel superior con sus
amenazas nucleares y el apoyo a los
referendos considerados ilegales en el
este de Ucrania por ello propone un
nuevo paquete de sanciones ya es el
octavo en cuya medida principal es la de
aplicar un tope al precio del petróleo
ruso recordemos la Unión Europea ya no
importará más petróleo proveniente de
Rusia a partir de diciembre pero se
trata de aplicar un tope para los
terceros países países en vías de
desarrollo que por ejemplo sigan
comprando petróleo a Rusia pero que lo
hagan a un precio mucho más barato y así
evitar que Rusia siga ganando dinero con
la compraventa del petróleo ahora mismo
se trata de aplicar una base legal para
poderlo introducir además la comisión
europea también propone que ciudadanos
europeos no puedan formar parte de
consejos de administración de empresas
rusas y así evitar casos como el del ex
canciller alemán gerards roda estuvo
durante años trabajando para gasprom
estas medidas y otras prohibiciones a la
exportación de productos químicos se
tendrán que hablar dentro de los países
para poderlas aplicar y así que puedan
entrar en vigor todas estas sanciones
también se añaden al malestar que ha
generado para la Unión Europea las fugas
en el gasoductos 1 y 2 para la Unión
Europea no es ninguna coincidencia y ya
hablan abiertamente de sabota